i i don't see him leaving willingly i
don't see him leaving
under any condition including people
knocking on the door with guns but he'd
be scarface
i just don't see this man giving it up
and i just think he's he has many cards
he hasn't played yet
he is not going to leave until
he wants to leave i i don't think he
would even leave if he lost
an election in 2020. oh i'm the guy who
says he's not leaving even if he loses
the election
people have been saying i'm an alarmist
and i'm crazy because i keep saying he's
not going to leave even if he loses
i don't think he's leaving he's not
going to leave
even if he loses the election so i'm a
third-rate respected comedian
yeah who says if he loses he's not
leaving no i've been saying for a very
long time now that i don't think he's
leaving listen i will bet you a million
dollars right now that if you lose the
2020 election
i'm right and you won't leave but he's
not leaving
he probably would have lost the election
trump and he probably
will not leave you know he's made me
part of his act because i always say
he's not going to leave
he's not leaving on january 20th because
if trump loses the election in november
he's not going to leave
i've been saying for a number of years
that if trump uh
loses the election he's not going to
leave i cannot picture that man
gracefully conceding and walking away
you're the only person i could get
interested in my theory
that trump was not going to leave
you